sometimes understatements are hilarious
I have maybe the biggest understatement
from the political world of the last
several months aides to Donald Trump are
worried he may not fully grasp for the
North Korea situation how could anybody
not realize that I read the headline and
thought to myself
it isn't just staffers that are
questioning Trump's grasp of the North
Korea situation there's this report in
New York magazine which explains the
Donald Trump has been just totally
perplexed every step of the way with the
North Korea stuff most recently when
North Korea as I told you last week
threatened to cancel the upcoming summit
Trump spoke to the South Korean
president moon jae-in and asked why is
North Korea saying one thing to you and
something else publicly like he just
doesn't even understand how North Korea
works at the most fundamental level he's
been asking friends and staffers whether
he should even go to the summit because
of the fear of getting embarrassed
politically is now clear even to Trump
which exposes that Trump really didn't
understand that possibility before and
Trump is reportedly saying internally at
the White House that quote everyone
thinks that he deserves a Nobel Peace
Prize for his work on North Korea
despite the reality that he has nothing
to do with the possibility of there
actually being something that changes in
North Korea and that nothing has
actually happened yet he's going around
the White House telling people he really
deserves that Nobel Peace Prize and then
the big revelation is that Trump
staffers don't think Trump understands
even the basics of what North Korea does
and what a deal would even look like
right so like that the fear is that
Trump doesn't know if there were to be
denuclearization what would be the
components of a deal right and moon
jae-in the South Korean president does
know this stuff and was able to speak to
Kim jong-un about it during their
meeting Kim jong-un also has high
facility in talking about nuclear
research and development how would Trump
even have a conversation at the summit
where he doesn't come off like a total
[ __ ] and and of course part of the
problem according to Trump staff is that
he's not getting any of the briefings
about things like enrichment
capabilities reap
processing plutonium how nukes are made
what the missile programs are that
Barack Obama and even George W Bush sort
of had a working understanding of so
yeah like is it this super obvious how
could Donald Trump even understand
anything if you won't read a thing he
won't sit through a detailed oral
briefing the shocking news to me would
be Trump has a great understanding of
this or any political issue the headline
that aides are concerned just tells us
the aides accurately see what it is
that's going on with Trump and he's not
even going to be able to talk to Kim
jong-un in any coherent way about this
yeah you got a study you got to keep up
to date on all this stuff and that's why
the presidential daily briefing is so
important and if you're not an expert
yourself you should at least have
experts around you to make the right
decisions I don't know if even like John
Bolton John Kelly are the right people
for that job well Stephen Miller might
be able to add something of value I
don't know right Steve Miller even
something like trade right like Trump
talked about trade since the beginning
of the campaign the guy barely
understands that issue like who would be
confused into thinking Trump understands
North Korean nuclear research Trump's
understanding of North Korea is so poor
that he probably wouldn't even realize
it if the stomach mat summit backfired
right like it he could end up
embarrassed by Kim jong-un and come back
and say we won like we did this amazing
thing in North Korean in Singapore
wherever the meeting ultimately will be
held seems like it will be Singapore I
hope for the best but we really need to
be prepared for the total absolute worst
when it comes to this summit and the
trend is that the people with most
confidence and Trump are the ones who
aren't near him right it's like people
on Twitter people on reddit out-of-touch
voters that get interviewed by CNN or
whoever the people working with the
guide day-to-day people like Bill Gates
in Elon Musk who get into a room with
Trump occasionally they realize the
guy's not playing with a full deck and
doesn't know anything and it's good that
some of the a is around Trump are
realizing they attic that exact same
thing the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad